- This episode of Legal Eagle
was made possible by Skillshare,
learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
(dramatic string music)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
and I am incredibly
excited to be coming to you
live from VidCon in
this ridiculous mansion
that I wish I could show you more of,
because it's just absolutely insane.
And luckily we have one of
my personal favorite creators
and probably the greatest
productivity expert on YouTube
in this day and age,
and that is Thomas Frank.
Thomas, thank you so much for being on
"Lawyer Interviews YouTubers
and Answers Their Legal Questions",
so thanks for being here.
- Yeah, no problem.
I can't believe you called
my house insane though.
- You know, you have a
very interesting style.
One might call it Trump-esque.
(laughing)
- I'm really rich!
- Yeah, VidCon just
brings a lot of craziness.
- Well, so,
why don't you tell some of the
Legal Eagles out there a
little bit about your channel,
because I think a lot of
people could really benefit
from the kind of stuff
that you are an expert in
and you talk about all
the time on your channel.
- Yeah, so, primarily I
focus on academic success
and productivity.
It's not just for students anymore,
but it definitely started off
as a student-focused channel.
Originally it was all
College Info Geek branding
which is my website,
and as time went on I
realized high school students,
middle school students, teachers,
young grads, all kinds of
people were watching the videos
and I moved out of school I realized
a lot of the same techniques
we use to learn effectively in college
translate to being an effective employee
or an effective entrepreneur,
or what have you.
So now,
it's kind of hard to describe
exactly what my channel is,
other than to say I help
people become more capable,
whether it's getting the career they want,
building their financial base
and becoming self-reliant,
or just improving the way that they learn
and get things done.
- Yeah, I think that's a
great way of describing it.
It's impossible to go to your channel
and not become a more efficient
and productive person.
So I definitely recommend
everyone check out your channel.
I understand that you are a
business person, yourself,
and that you have taken some
of the tools and systems
that you created for college
and have turned that into a whole business
in and of itself, right?
- I am a business, man.
(laughing)
Yeah, I've, we've got
I think seven people
on the team right now,
so it's kinda crazy, y'know.
This business literally
started in my dorm room
during a summer job
and now it's seven people,
five of which are in Denver
and then we got a couple
of remote contractors.
So it's been a wild ride,
and there have been many nights
staying up Googling, y'know,
esoteric legalese to figure out
if I'm doing things correctly or not,
and I hope I am, but...
- Well, let's take this
opportunity to talk about
some of the sort of general things that
either you or people in your
situation have come across?
- Yeah, I've actually got
a couple of things in mind.
So the first one I wanna talk about
is working with contractors.
Because I work with an editor now
and he works nearly full-time with me
though he may be takin'
on some extra contracts
here and there, on the side.
I've got a few other people who work
nearly full-time, and
then a few people who work
just a few hours a week.
And what a lot of people
always ask, when they start,
y'know, working with editors,
working with contractors is
what defines a contractor
who's independent
from an employee?
And, I mean as you know,
there are many differences
from the businessperson's perspective,
an employee, you have to provide benefits,
you have to provide a
whole host of other things,
you got payroll going,
and with a contract it's,
it's really just, y'know, a
1099 at the end of the year
if you're American,
and, y'know, either a handshake agreement
or a written contract and
that's kind of it, so,
from the perspective of the
person running the business,
it's a lot easier to do the
contractor route, right?
- Often, yeah, and I think you hinted at
some of the repercussions
that come as a result
of making that distinction
between someone that you're working with
and saying that they are
an independent contractor
versus an employee.
There are of course the benefits
that you have to deal with,
but there are all kinds
of legal protections
that are afforded for employees
that are not afforded to
independent contractors
and there are tons of
tax implications, too.
And I wish I could give you
a really satisfying answer
that here are the three
things that you must do,
but unfortunately, in most states
and under the federal government, as well,
there are tons of different standards
depending on which jurisdiction you're in,
and on top of that, almost
all of the standards
have dozens of different
questions that you have to answer
in terms of weighing one way or the other,
and there's no bright line.
Under the federal
guidelines, the US government
tends to break it up into three sections,
there's behavioral control,
there's financial control,
and then there is the relationship itself.
And you're just weighing a
bunch of different factors,
so in terms of behavioral control,
if the employer, whether
you're employing an employee
or an independent contractor,
has the right to define how
the person does their work,
that leads to more of an employee
than an independent contractor,
whereas if the person
who is doing the work
can control the manner in which it's done,
if they use their own tools,
if they have the ability to start and stop
whenever they want,
that's more indicative of
an independent contractor
versus an employee.
On top of it, there is a question of
can they be fired at any time,
or if they have to stay for
the duration of the job.
And ironically, if you have the
right to fire them whenever,
that's more of an employee relationship.
Yeah, if you have the
right and the obligation
to finish the job,
that's more of an independent contractor,
because generally the
independent contractor is more of
a person who is hired for a specific job.
And that leads to some of
the financial considerations,
is the second overarching question,
including the financial
control of the worker.
If the worker has the
ability to make decisions
that will affect the profitability
of that specific job,
that is more of an independent
contractor, so, like,
someone like a video editor, for example,
they could choose to work
all night and get a job done
or they could choose to
work whenever they want
and those are decisions that
can affect the profitability
of the job.
- Which makes them more of a contractor?
- Correct, correct.
And, y'know, the big one,
traditionally, has been
are you allowed to work with other people.
So, part of the classic
independent contractor is like
a plumber that owns Bob's
Plumbing Company and,
he might work with you and he
might work with a whole bunch
of other people,
and that kind of financial
freedom is something
that is indicative
of an independent contractor relationship.
We think of employees as having one job,
you show up nine to
five, you get a salary,
and you can't work for anybody else,
you're not really supposed to moonlight.
Whereas an independent
contractor is generally someone
that can work on their own hours,
can work for whomever they want,
and are, they're paid
by the job instead of,
y'know, a salary.
- Now I do have a question there.
- [Host] Sure.
- Is that determined on whether
or not they have the option
to work with other clients
or whether or not they literally are?
So say, y'know, I've
given someone a contract
that effectively buys up all of the time
that they would be
willing to work normally,
but they still have the freedom
to work with somebody else
if they have the time
or if they wanted to work 80
hours a week or something,
that could still be a
contractor situation, right?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
And for the most part, it
is based on their ability,
not the actual,
on the ground status quo
of what has happened, so
it is the ability to work for other people
and not just whether, y'know,
they have actually gone out
and gotten other clients
or have chosen not to.
So, for the most part an
employee is someone that
doesn't have the ability
one way or the other,
they are stuck with their employer
and then that goes right to
the nature of the relationship,
which is the third thing that the IRS
and the federal government looks to,
which can be defined by
things like the contract.
Just because you write in
the contract with someone
that they are independent
contractor or an employee,
that's not dispositive,
but it's certainly good
evidence one way or the other,
because we like to sort of
reward the meeting of the minds
and we assume that if
you signed the contract
that you have agreed to those terms
and that's good evidence
that you have agreed to
that particular relationship.
And of course,
y'know, the law is what it is.
So, just because you've
written it in a contract
doesn't mean it's true.
But, y'know, it helps to
define that relationship.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And then classically,
along with that relationship
is the question of benefits.
And if you provide them to the worker
then that is another piece of evidence
that they are an employee
rather than an independent contractor.
- So if you start providing benefits,
out of the goodness of your
own heart, or something,
that would actually start to move you
into that employee classification?
- No good deed goes
unpunished in the legal world.
(laughing)
Yeah, that is, that's
definitely how it can go.
- Okay, so I have one final
follow-up question for you,
and this is for people who
just, working on their own,
maybe they have contractors,
maybe they don't,
but I would say the majority
of YouTubers out there
are sole proprietors.
At least, the ones in the US,
or maybe there's an equivalent overseas,
but, y'know, you are the business.
You are a business, man.
So the profit of the
business is your paycheck
and that's kind of all there is to it.
So, for those people,
what is the benefit of establishing LLC
or some other kind of, like,
legal entity for your business
that separates you from it?
- Yeah, it's a great question,
and there are a lot of myths about it.
It's really fairly simple, because,
as you say, as a sole
proprietor, if you incur a debt
on behalf of your company,
or you do something wrong
and you incur liability for
a contract or some torte,
the person who's been wronged
can come after you personally.
So the point of having an entity at all
is to shield liability so that
if someone files a lawsuit
they can get all the assets of the company
but they can't come at you
and your personal assets.
And so that can be a very important thing,
it's effectively a type
of insurance, to make sure
that there's a barrier
between what your company does
and what happens to you.
And traditionally,
historically, in order to get
that kind of protection,
you had to form a regular corporation.
Which was taxed when profits
come in to the company
and then taxed again when
you take those profits out
and you take a salary as individuals.
- Yeah, double taxation-based.
- And that is a very American thing.
Ironically, a lot of
European countries don't have
quite that double system
of double taxation
and one thing that most states have done
is created sort of a hybrid
system which is an entity
that provides some liability insurance
but from a tax perspective,
you don't have to pay double
taxation and it's called,
what's called a pass-through.
So, the profits come into the company,
they aren't taxed at the company level,
but the taxes at the end of the year
are considered your personal income.
And so you will pay personal income taxes
on the profits that come to you.
So from a creator perspective,
the reason you might wanna create a LLC
is to shield yourself
from potential liability
from crazy people that
are out there, or y'know,
maybe lawsuits that you might get into.
It allows you to have that
same kind of legal protection
while only paying taxes once
as income tax when it comes to you.
- [Thomas] So financially, you're still,
you're still the business, essentially.
But legally, you are not.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Now, I've heard that it's a myth that
that liability protection is bulletproof.
- Yeah, that is definitely the case.
When you form an entity,
whether it's an LLC
or a corporation, what generally
businesspeople need to do
is they need to have a
separate business account
and you have to be very careful about
separating all of your business things
from your personal things.
Because there's a
concept in the law called
piercing the corporate veil,
where the court will say
"You're not really two separate things,
you've mixed your own money
with the corporation's money
and as a result we're going to
disregard the corporate form
and we're just gonna go
after you in particular".
So, y'know, if you have, if
someone has questions about them
there are some really
good resources online
that will help you form an
LLC and explain the process
but the last thing you wanna
do is go through the hassle
of forming an entity only to
basically make it null and
void and lose that protection.
- Yeah, I know my accountant
told me is have a separate
business bank account,
separate personal bank account,
and then, up from there,
separate y'know, credit card
that you pay with your
personal bank account
and then a business credit card you pay
with your business bank account,
and that also makes the
accounting a lot easier, too,
because you can use those apps
that just pull in the bank
account statements and
automatically just, y'know,
reconcile your transactions
for you, essentially.
And you're not picking
and choosing which ones
are personal and business.
- Yeah, I totally agree,
if the business credit card
goes straight to the business account,
then really the stuff at the
end of the year is super easy
'cause you just send your
accounting information
for your business accounts
to your accountant
and they can figure out
all the tax implications
right from there.
- Yeah, and you're all good to go.
- So, you can't help but
bring productivity tips
wherever you go, Thomas,
everyone is gonna be
forming entities and
streamlining their finances.
I can't thank you enough for coming down
and dropping some
productivity wisdom bombs
on all of us Legal Eagles,
despite our interest in the law
and I highly recommend
everyone to check out Thomas's
YouTube channel, this is really
just the tip of the iceberg
and Thomas makes everyone
far, far more efficient
than when they walked through the door.
So, Thomas, thank you so much.
- Yeah, and thank you
for the legal answers.
(eagle screeching)
- [Host] Okay, that's a wrap everyone,
hey, thanks for doin'
this interview, Thomas.
You know, Thomas, have you
ever heard of Skillshare?
It's an online learning platform
with over 30,000 classes.
I think you'd really like it.
Whoa, what's that?
You have a Skillshare class already?
It's called "the
Productivity Master Class:
How to Create a Custom System that Works".
It teaches people how to transform
their personal and
professional life by creating
simple, customized productivity systems?
Yeah, I guess that does sound pretty good.
I mean, I guess people
should go watch that.
Okay, fine, smarty pants,
but did you know that Legal
Eagles will get two free months
of Skillshare when you
click on the link below?
Well, they do!
No, I don't care if
you have your own code,
they should use my code,
because clicking on the
URL below really helps out
this channel, y'know, the
one that we're on right now.
Y'know, the free Premium
Skillshare membership
gives you unlimited access
to must-know topics so you
can improve your skills
and learn new things.
So, y'know, people
should click on the link
and get two free months and start learning
to think like a lawyer today.
Yes, yeah, even you, Thomas Frank,
who I am definitely talking
to in real time right now.